Here's an example of a lookup for an A
record for gottech.edu. You can try this at your own
command line by typing, for example, dig www.gottech.edu. Now
there are some interesting things to note in this trace.
Here is our query and you can see that
this is an A record query. Here's our answer. You
can see that the answer actually has a C name
in it, which basically says, well you asked for gottech.edu
but in fact what you really want to
ask for is tlweb.gtm.gottech.edu. So then we issue an
A record query for that name, and we ultimately
get the IP address. These numbers here indicate the
time to live or the amount of time in
seconds that the entry can be stored in the
cache. Here's another example of a DNS lookup from
nytimes.com. The interesting thing to note here is that
in response to the A record query, we see two
IP addresses. This is typically performed when a service wants
to perform load balancing So, the client could use either
one of these. It might prefer the first one, but if
we issued the same query again, we might actually get
these IP addresses in a different order. Now, again, here you
can see the TTL value which indicates how long these
A records can be scored in cache. In a subsequent example,
we'll look at other query types that have
much longer TTL values. Here's an example of a
query for the NS record for gatech.edu. You
can see this output by typing dignsgatech.edu. You can
see here in the question section, now instead of an A record query we have an NS
record query. And our answer is a bunch
of NS records that are dns1, 2, and 3.gatech.edu,
any of which could answer authoritatively for sub-domains
of gatech.edu. You can see that in addition
to the answer, which return the name servers,
we also need the IP addresses of those name
servers, which is returned in the additional section
of the answer. You can see here that we
received not only A records for each domain
name but also quad A or IPv6 addresses corresponding
to each authoritative name server. Here's an example
of a query for an MX record or the
mail server corresponding to gatech.edu. Now here again, you
can the question is the MX record and you
can see the answer which returns two mail servers.
As well as the additional section, which returns an
A record, indicating the IP address corresponding to the
mail server that was returned in the MX record.
In addition to the TTL, we also have some metrics
that indicate priorities, that it would allow a system administrator to
configure a primary and a backup mail server. In this case,
the mail servers, just happen to have the same priority level.